estoy muy contento porque parece ser que
este va a ser el último vídeo de los
vídeos de los problemas del stm estamos
en la sección número 8 en el examen
número 8 sección número 8 y bueno nos
faltan tres problemas para acabar todos
los problemas del libro y es por eso que
estoy bastante emocionado vamos a
ponernos a trabajar en los últimos tres
problemas para que no se me acabe el
tiempo y no me trabé en ello y tengamos
tiempo de sobra estábamos en el problema
número 14 en el problema número 14 y
vamos a resolverlo así que ok con mucha
alegría vamos a meterle todo todo a este
último vídeo del st
tengo dos rectas paralelas una como ésta
y otra como ésta son paralelas y después
tengo una renta más o menos así algo así
y otra recta más o menos así ok y me
dicen que a tenemos algunos nombres me
dicen que esta recta se llama m esta
recta se llama l m y l son paralelas eso
nos dice el problema
y me dicen que este ángulo se llama z
este ángulo se llama x y este de acá se
llama jr y que es lo que me preguntan
cuánto vale z en términos de x y deejay
ok y parece que empezamos con un
problema bastante sencillo porque este
tipo de problemas los hemos visto varias
veces es el juego de los ángulos o vamos
a cazar ángulos si yo lo que quiero es
hace está en términos de xy de ye sería
muy bueno encontrar una relación de los
tres pero lo primero que quiero que te
des cuenta es que sabemos que está bien
es exactamente este mismo ángulo porque
son ángulos opuestos por el vértice por
lo tanto estos dos ángulos son iguales y
éste también se llama james y además
tenemos dos rectas paralelas y como
tenemos dos rectas paralelas entonces
tenemos ángulos congruentes este ángulo
es lo mismo que este ángulo de aquí
estos dos ángulos son iguales que a su
vez son iguales a este de aquí ya este
de aquí por lo tanto como son
congruentes éste también se llama james
y éste también se llama
de lujo ya tengo aquí a ayer y está
padrísimo porque la pasé para camps y
aquí me va a servir bastante porque ya
tengo hay en ax y hace está en un mismo
triángulo y recuerdas qué es lo que pasa
cuando tengo los tres ángulos de un
triángulo bueno pues ya sea una relación
entre ellos recuerda que la suma de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo siempre
es 180 grados por lo tanto aquí ya tengo
qué zx3 unos ángulos internos de este
triángulo y entonces x más
+ z la suma de los tres me tienen que
dar 180 grados y de aquí de que ya estoy
a un paso para encontrar a z en términos
de x de m
aquí puede despejar a z y decir que z es
igual o que esté 180 lo voy a dejar
igual y voy a restar x de ambos lados de
esta ecuación menos x y también voy a
restar de ambos lados de la ecuación
- jeff de tal manera que de este lado se
van a cancelar y ahora si llamo que 12
está despejada z es igual a 180 menos x
- jeff a 10 la relación de z en términos
de xy de james que por cierto es mi
inciso y es mi éxito y es la respuesta
de este problema número 14 así que este
fue el antepenúltimo el antepenúltimo
problema de todos los problemas del este
tema vamos a decirle adiós y vamos a
resolver el penúltimo así que borremos
esto y vamos ahora al problema número 15
me voy a tomar este color
problema número 15 y dice lo siguiente
si n y camps son enteros positivos
entonces cuánto vale cam en la siguiente
expresión y tengo la expresión
n entre en el -1 ok x 1 / n 1 / n por n
n / n 1 y dicen que esto es igual a 5 /
k ok a nk entre los positivos cuando
beckham bueno lo primero que yo puedo
ver en esta expresión de aquí es que la
podemos reducir un poco a qué me refiero
aquí tengo una n multiplicando y aquí
una n dividiendo vamos a cancelar las
está con esta se van y entonces a ya no
se puede reducir nada más y entonces
podemos escribir esta fracción de la
siguiente manera esto es lo mismo que
uno por n lo cual es n entre a n menos
uno por n 1 am y lo voy a poner así
en menos 1 por n 1 y aunque yo sé que
esto me va a dar una diferencia de
cuadrados es mejor ponerlo así por
ahorita para ver qué se nos ocurre y
dicen que esto es igual a 5 entre acá ok
y yo lo que quiero es un valor de camps
o que yo creo que escriba se me ocurrió
la idea fíjate bien yo tengo que esa
expresión no está diciendo que n entre n
1 por n más uno tiene que ser igual a 5
entre otra cosa entonces yo comparo
estas dos fracciones para que se cumpla
esta igualdad yo podría decir que en ee
es igual a 5 es decir que el numerador
es igual a esta parte del numerador o un
múltiplo de 5 si estas dos fracciones
son iguales y comparamos estas dos
fracciones encontramos que el patrón
podría ser que ns a 5 entonces n puede
ser que sean 5 o puede ser que sea un
múltiplo de 5 pero bueno recuerda que
casi todos los problemas del stm tienen
una solución en general sencilla por lo
tanto vamos a suponer que en es igual a
5 y vamos a ver si llega
a una respuesta es decir lo que estoy
tomándome es que esta parte de arriba
esta parte de aquí va a ser igual a esta
parte de aquí ok y entonces eso quiere
decir que la parte de abajo que esto de
aquí va a tener que ser igual a esta
parte de aquí a esta parte de aquí que
es justo lo que queremos el valor de
campo si yo digo que n es igual a 5
entonces en menos uno por n
uno debe de ser igual a camps ahora
fíjate bien que no forzosamente n debe
de ser 5 estoy suponiendo que es 5 pero
también puede ser cualquier múltiplo de
5 recuerda que podría ser una fracción
la cual se simplifique en esta de aquí
ok entonces si n vale 5 a ver cuánto
vale cam bueno pues en este caso acá acá
vale en el -1 que multiplica a n 1 ok
pero n valdés 5 estamos suponiendo que
en de vale 5 entonces acá me quedaría
como un 5 menos 1 ok
5 - 1 que multiplican así
+ 151 y que va a ser igual
5 - 1 944 por 6 es 24 24 en este caso en
el que estamos suponiendo que n vale 5 k
debe de valer 24 y estas mis respuestas
a sibaya que si esta esta es la
respuesta se cae igual a 24 y está de
lujo no encontramos este problema con un
patrón de comparación de dos fracciones
de estas dos fracciones que tenemos aquí
y ya está
así encuentro la solución de este
problema número 15 así que vamos a
resolver el último el último problema de
este examen número 8 esta sección número
8 y para eso voy a borrar el pizarrón y
voy a utilizar el color salmón el color
salmón me va a dar el problema número 16
efe dieciséis el problema número 10 y no
el problema número 16 problemas número
16 que dice lo siguiente para celebrar
una graduación de colegas de m
compañeros de trabajo se realizará una
comida para la cual se necesitan juntar
entre todos de pesos ok
tengo a mi colegas de trabajo m a
compañeros de trabajo con
2 de trabajo de trabajo ok y se
necesitan juntar lo voy a cambiar con
otro color se están juntando 10 pesos de
pesos para realizar su comida de
graduación ok si ve de los trabajadores
fallaron con la contribución o que creo
que ellos no nos van a invitar a la
comunidad pero esta vez vamos a ponerle
así que no contribuyen con
y en la cooperación puede los siguientes
incisos muestran en pesos el dinero
extra que tendrán que contribuir los
trabajadores restantes para que se
realice la comida ok si van a hacer la
comida aunque estos pe no contribuyeron
pero si antes les tocaba una cierta
cantidad a cada uno de los m compañeros
pues falta reunir otra cierta cantidad
de las personas que no contribuyeron y
también se la van a dividir entre estos
mismos compañeros de trabajo así que
vamos a pensar en el antes y el después
fíjate bien
si pensamos en un inicio en un inicio
tenemos 10 pesos que juntar estos de
aquí y entonces hay pesos los íbamos a
dividir entre la cantidad de personas
que había que son m
/ m / m y si te das cuenta
aquí tenemos una fracción y esta
fracción nos dice cuánto le tocaba poner
a cada uno de los m compañeros de
trabajo para que se hiciera la comida
sin embargo pd ellos deciden no
contribuir no tienen dinero o cualquier
cosa y por lo tanto ahora necesitamos
todas
juntando 10 pesos necesitamos juntar los
pesos seguimos con esta cantidad de
dinero pero ahora son menos la cantidad
de personas que van a contribuir cuántas
personas van a contribuir bueno pues lo
podemos pensar así
a m/m le voy a quitar los pe que no van
a contribuir a m le voy a quitar le voy
a quitar los pe que no van a contribuir
esta es una cantidad de personas que si
van a contribuir
que si van a ir a la comida y aquí tengo
ahora representado lo que va a tener que
aportar cada uno de ellos para que si se
realice la comida y si te das cuenta
este valor de aquí es mucho más grande
que este valor de camps o bueno no mucho
más grande pero depende de pep lo que sí
quiero que veas es que esta desigualdad
se cumple esto de aquí es más grande que
este de acá y eso lo podemos ver de la
siguiente manera aquí tengo ya entre m y
aquí tengo y entre algo más pequeño a ml
estoy quitando algo y por lo tanto este
valor es más pequeño y si yo tengo algo
dividido entre algo más pequeño es más
grande que tener dividido algo entre
algo más grande
creo que si me explique un poco bueno ya
que tengo esta desigualdad yo lo que
quiero saber es a no cuánto nos tocaba
en un principio ni cuánto les toca ahora
sino cuánto dinero les toca extra a cada
uno de los trabajadores para que sea
complete el dinero de la comida
ahora bien dinero extra el dinero extra
que va a aportar cada uno de ellos para
que si se haga la comida y bueno
realmente lo que me tengo que tomar es
la diferencia y cambiamos a este color
realmente lo que tengo que tomarme es la
diferencia de éste
entre m - p - y entre m fíjate que esto
es más grande que éste y por lo tanto si
los podemos restar y vamos a obtener un
número positivo y además fíjate lo que
está diciendo esta expresión de aquí
esta expresión de aquí lo que me está
diciendo es a la cantidad que va a tener
que aportar ahora cada uno de ellos ya
contando que p no van a contribuir les
voy a quitar la cantidad que
originalmente tenían que contribuir es
decir me estoy tomando la diferencia de
lo que ahora
que contribuir menos lo que antes tenía
que contribuir y esto me va a dar pues
precisamente el margen es decir el
dinero extra que van a tener que aportar
cada uno de ellos y perfecto justo lo
que tengo que hacer es esta resta de
aquí am y la voy a hacer por acá dice
james / m
p - y / m y bueno aquí puedo sacar un
denominador común ni denominador común
es m que multiplica a m
p recuerda que como tenemos puras letras
y no sabemos cuánto vale m
p ni cuánto vale m entonces el
denominador común siempre va a ser la
multiplicación de ambos o dicho de otra
manera el mínimo común múltiplo entre
estos dos que no sabemos quiénes son es
a la multiplicación de ambos entonces m
que multiplica a m - p es también
denominador común y bueno como sacó la
parte de arriba como sacó el numerador
para esto voy a hacer m por m
/ m menos pp y lo voy a multiplicar por
el de arriba
y cuántos eso bueno m por m
p / m p es m m por james es m 10m y ya
esto le voy a quitar ok
ahora no voy a tomar lo mismo pero para
esta fracción m por m - p / m pues me va
a quedar esto se cancelan me va a quedar
solamente el otro es decir en menos pm
emen - p por james es que multiplica a m
- p ok
lo único que estoy haciendo es teniendo
mucho cuidado con este nuevo denominador
para ver qué es lo que me queda de cada
de la multiplicación de cada uno de
ellos es decir estoy escribiendo estas
fracciones conforme al nuevo denominador
a este denominador común y bueno a esto
todavía no están mis respuestas o es que
ya veo 7 aquí se va a cancelar algo
fíjate fíjate vamos el siguiente paso a
esto es exactamente lo mismo que m por
james menos - por más menos m porque m
por qué y después menos por menos me va
a dar más bien por p s&p ya esto lo voy
a dividir lo voy a dividir entre m que
multiplica a m
ok y esto lo estoy haciendo porque aquí
se pueden reducir dos términos ya te
diste cuenta m bien menos m
bien pues estos dos se van vámonos y
solamente me quedo con
10 pm / m que multiplica a m - p de lujo
esta es la respuesta de este problema si
si existe es el inciso en el éxito y me
dice justo esto ya ha simplificado ya
así es la operación de este problema me
queda que ye p / m por m - p es la
solución de este problema y no hace que
este problema estuvo un poco abstracto
pero realmente lo único que hice fue
tomarme la diferencia de lo que antes
contribuyan a comparación de lo que
ahora necesitan contribuir después de
que no van a contribuir ok
bueno creo que fue un poco abstracto
este problema pero lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que por fin acabamos con
esto hemos realizado un buen ejercicios
como cuántos se habrán sido fueron ocho
exámenes y cada uno de ellos tiene más o
menos como cincuenta y cuatro ejercicios
como cincuenta y cuatro ejercicios y
cuánto es esto 8 por 54 es lo mismo que
432 432 hemos hecho como 432 ejercicios
todos los problemas del s 3 432
problemas sad y con esto yo creo que ya
estás preparado para presentar el examen
del s ate y sacar la calificación
perfecta si te va bien en el examen por
favor házmelo saber comentan en este
vídeo o hazme un comentario en alguno de
los vídeos para saber qué te fue
bastante bien
yo estaré muy feliz de que esto suceda
así que bueno pues nos vemos en a bueno
no en el siguiente vídeo del 'siete'
pero pues será en otro de mis vídeos y
si tal vez algún día sale un nuevo libro
sobre problemas del st haga todo esto de
nuevo todos estos vídeos sobre sus
ejercicios en fin mucha suerte en tu
examen y nos vemos pronto